hello New Jersey and good morning
Albuquerque on today's show we're
revisiting two of the most binge tastic
TV shows ever that would change the face
of entertainment and of Gus fring
forever
it's Breaking Bad versus The Sopranos in
one quarter you have a drug kingpin
dealing with health issues while trying
to protect his family and the other
quarter is a mob kingpin dealing with
health issues while trying to protect
his family Walter White and Tony Soprano
they might have been great business
partners Skyler and Carmela could have
been BFFs it may be while jr. takes
meadow to prom who knows you're born to
this [ __ ] you are what you are well each
program has tons of prequel material in
the works
unfortunately no crossover series is
imminent thus it's my duty to determine
one and only one winner in a crown of
destined show wait dawg no sorry just
best [ __ ] here's how we'll decide a
victor round 1 tomato meter round 2
popularity round 3 characters and then
we'll do a wild-card around to help take
care of that thing phenom abul get ready
for tons of tracksuits rvs gold chains
and 99% pure blue methamphetamine
breakfasty check that's get this thing
going
I'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] one who
closed the shots tread lightly round 1
tomato meter way back in 1999 when Peter
Gibbons and initech were frantically
updating software for y2k David chase
created a little mob show to air on HBO
the cable network that was famous for
showing movies and the Larry Sanders
Show once The Sopranos hit television
would never be the same and the critics
fell in love right from the get-go
the show debuted without 100% first
season on the tomato meter and it would
go on to boast seasons at least in the
90s all the way until its final bow
season 6 which collected 89% and 83% for
its two parts all told the show averaged
92 percent which is definitely good
enough to get meadow into Brown and more
importantly it gives its competition a
huge standard to live up to you must
have been at the top of your [ __ ]
class Breaking Bad creator Vince
Gilligan watch the show on AMC in 2008
and the pilot was famous for having the
Sai
fell dentist running around the desert
in his tighty whities season once
started to gather critical acclaim and
by its end it could boast an 86% on the
tomato meter for its debut each new
season brought more eyeballs and parades
with seasons three and four winning a
perfect 100 percent each time and its
fifth and final season wrap things up
with a 97% that all makes for 96%
average and for funsies the Netflix
continuation of Jesse Pinkman story El
Camino has a 95 percent of the tomato
meter and prequel series better call
Saul currently has an average of 96
percent that is some impressive
television yeah there's some whites
yes science well we're still waiting on
that Sopranos prequel film so let's just
see how the two shows themselves back up
96% for Breaking Bad 92 percent for The
Sopranos but The Sopranos does score
bonus points by paving the way for shows
like breaking bad to even exist but it
doesn't fear that critics felt the drug
show stuck the landing a little bit more
and give us a more satisfying conclusion
than the mob show fair enough with a
combined four seasons at a hundred
percent of the tomato meter virtually
every other TV drama or any artistic
endeavor for that matter is looking up
at both The Sopranos and Breaking Bad
but if only one show can take the round
one win
I gotta lean towards the one that had a
steady rise to the top and stayed there
Breaking Bad nailed the dismount and
goes up one nothing you clearly don't
know who you're talking to so let me
clue you in I am NOT in danger Skyler I
am the danger a guy opens his door and
gets shot and you think that of me
no I am the one who knocks number 2
popularity considered two of the best
shows ever I'm not sure Breaking Bad in
The Sopranos even have competition
post-2000 right Peter Griffin Breaking
Bad is the best show I've ever seen
except maybe the Wyatt okay well
Baltimore exploits aside audiences have
been hooked on these two programs and
the ratings certainly reflect that The
Sopranos opened up with an average of
almost 11 million viewers per episode
for its first season and it got close to
those gaudy numbers again in its third
season the final season averaged 8.6
three
million viewers with the final episode
having eleven point nine million live
viewers which means eleven point eight
million people immediately called the
cable company afterwards to complain
that their TV went out during the
biggest moment in television history
[Music]
Breaking Bad and it's AMC viewership
can't compete pound for pound with the
HBO digits as every season averaged one
to two million viewers per episode until
season 5 which pulled in 4.2 3 million
average views and although an impressive
10.2 eight million folks watched the
series finale live then immediately were
reminded what a great band Badfinger was
the overall series average viewers gives
The Sopranos a decisive advantage eight
million to 2 million
Konoe Quasimodo predicted old momentum
is with Tony Pauly Silvio in the gang
but what did audiences think after
watching these shows they liked it they
really really dug it it's virtually a
tie with the slightest of edges going to
Breaking Bad 98% to ninety seven point
eight percent the best seasons for each
show in terms of the audience score are
two and three for The Sopranos and three
and five for Breaking Bad here's the
real nutty thing Sopranos
last night a new episode in 2007 and
Breaking Bad said goodbye in 2013 yet
both shows are still amongst the most
binge shows today in 2030 what's that oh
it's only 2020 feels like a decade nice
huh if not for Breaking Bad with a nice
assist from The Walking Dead I'm not
sure AMC would be making original
content today and even though HBO has
had so many popular shows movies and
miniseries sense
check out HBO goes front page I'll wait
it's the freaking Sopranos they know
where their bread is buttered and it's
still in the swamps of Jersey better
ratings and a super competitive audience
score give The Sopranos the win in this
round and hopefully that satisfies Tony
until next week when I promise I'll have
the rest of the money
ran three characters folks not only do I
host this show I also get to write it
which is fun I'm clearly great at it as
the Pulitzer is behind me are gonna tell
you but it's rounds like this where I
really thank my lucky stars that I have
the experts at Rotten Tomatoes to
research these shows and provide me with
facts to come out of my mouth yeah The
Sopranos and Breaking Bad each have had
more characters in Springfield and
Shelbyville combined and to comb through
all of them is not only a huge task it
can also damage silly O's quaff it's
beautiful so let's start with our
protagonists anti-heroes outright bad
humans however you want to classify them
Tony Soprano and Walter what are the
modern archetypes of characters we begin
the show wanting and even expecting to
root for and then we just hold on to
dear life as they continue to descend
deeper into darkness violence and
questionable attire assisted by a genre
evolving writing James Gandolfini and
Bryan Cranston so brilliantly played
these parts that whether you hung on
their side until the end you jump ship
you pulled for them to meet their demise
at the next turn or you just stayed in
the middle like Malcolm what the [ __ ] is
the matter with you you are always
compelled to keep watching we had to see
what happened next and whether it was a
kind moment of compassion for a loved
one or heinous act we just couldn't
believe really happened it was great
entertainment to see you asked me if I
was in the meth business or the money
business neither I'm in the Empire
business and while they may never be
considered the most lovable of TV dads
they are fathers and had families to
look after the leaf you'll frigging
idiot Edie Falco and Anna Gunn deserve
so much praise for embodying the role of
a strong partner that accepts their
husband flaws and life choices to a
point once we reach that and once the
hubby goes too far they are the moral
conscience we desperately look for for
some semblance of sanity the kids also
give us hope for a better tomorrow even
as we see signs that their parents
behavior may be steering them
down a path of debatable moral fiber RJ
Mitte is Walt Jr is phenomenal for being
able to Center his father and bring out
the good in him more than anyone else
maybe we should ditch the jr. and change
it to Skywalker meadow and Tony jr.
quickly catch on to exactly what their
Pappy does in the world of waste
management and a continuously intriguing
subplot is how much that is going to
affect their own behavior immediately
assumes you're mobbed up with each new
season and episode for that matter
audiences were introduced to a seemingly
endless crop of allies enemies allies
that became enemies enemies that became
allies and some straight-up Psychopaths
Tony's crew if Paulie Silvio and Michael
formed a core of believable mob
Goodfellas who could alternate we
provide moments of levity and in the
next scene shock us with their ultra
violent brutality but it was inside a
therapist's office that Anthony was most
introspective courtesy of the note
perfect Lorraine Bracco as dr. Melfi
meanwhile Breaking Bad set up former
student Jesse Pinkman as the perfect
foil for Walt and a character capable of
carrying entire episodes of storylines
he really came a long way from the
original ending for season 1 when Vince
Gilligan was gonna plan to kill him off
imagine if we only got one seasons worth
of yo [ __ ] rolling further [ __ ]
the longer the Sopranos ran the more we
got big guest stars and meaningful roles
how about the addition of Joey pants
Steve Buscemi even the appearance of a
young John Favreau directing see this
show was so transcendent it practically
booked him the directing gig for Iron
Man I wouldn't want to be home when the
wise guys come collecting their
percentage of that movie thought we
wouldn't notice but we did but if both
shows are capable of giving us reluctant
evil against outright evil its Breaking
Bad that gave us the devilishly
entertaining and calculating persona of
Gustavo Fring not only is his cold
emotionless presence haunting and
captivating how delicious does Atlas
poised for monos restaurant look are
they competing with Popeyes for the best
chicken sandwich
I like answers on this looking out for
the bad guys is Hank the affable
everyman whose desire for justice and
occasional need for reading material on
the can prove more and more an
inconvenience for sir heisenberg we've
had the privilege of seeing some side
characters get more fleshed out and
better call Saul not the least of which
is the show's namesake Saul Goodman his
role got bigger and bigger on Breaking
Bad as the seasons progressed and just
personally I will never stop laughing at
the time he convinced a date that he was
Kevin Costner you are not Kevin Costner
was last night there's tons of important
players for both teams and to choose one
side over the other when it comes to
characters it's a fool's errand I'm just
the guy for the job and it erased this
close when I really can't decide one
show over the other I'm forced to go to
the smallest margins possible which show
had a cameo from Van Halen legend David
Lee Roth playing poker
it was The Sopranos and they get the win
in round three by the skin of their
teeth might as well jump Tony's crew
you're up two to one just Christ I'm Lee
such a no-go I was just gonna say he's a
nice guy I salute and now it's time for
the wild-card round most iconic and you
thought the character round was
jam-packed The Sopranos in Breaking Bad
have had so may I con ik moments while
we were watching their initial runs and
then when you go back and watch again
some events that seemed insignificant at
the time loom even larger today it's the
mark of a great show where you can go
back revisit and glean new insight even
though you know what the ultimate
outcome is since The Sopranos landed on
our TV sets first yet kids back then we
called them sets and circuitcity had a
great deal on a thirty five incher let's
take a walk down memory lane we clearly
weren't prepared for the carnage that
was to follow once we saw a peaceful
Tony feeding ducks in his pool at the
outset of the show and nothing could
have prepared us for Sylvia ending
audriana's life Wow
say it ain't so little Stevie even the
wax we expected have emotional value big
[ __ ] had it coming for a while but it's
still a gut punch when it all goes down
even the near deaths are heart wrenching
literally dr. melfi's heart attack
Michael getting bamboozled by those two
nitwits any number of passing out
moments from Tony and especially AJ
suicide attempt
yikes these and so many more moments run
the gamut from shocking to necessary but
after each one as an audience we feel
emotionally spent Breaking Bad a show in
part inspired by The Sopranos has
similar instances twists turns and death
Walt standing by while a certain person
dies is at the forefront of my mind as
his Danny Trejo head on a turtle Mike
speech about no half measures is epic
did I mention Mike the character in the
other rap my bad sorry Mike I'm sorry no
more half measures Walter Walt himself
must have taken some public speaking
classes because by the end of his run
he's given us some all timelines like
say my name I am the one who knocks and
tread lightly he means business
well nutbar Jesse just means pure uncut
evil just tell me you don't give a [ __ ]
about me and it's either this it's
either this or you'll kill me to say why
you killed Mike while we're talking
about all-time memorable scenes let's
not forget that in terms of iconic the
show's themself ranks super high no pun
intended Breaking Bad on pretty much
every best show ever list rolling stone
in the guardians list both have the
Sopranos at number one all-time
meanwhile Empire and rancor did lists
that saw Breaking Bad hit the top of the
charts in terms of awards both shows
have won an exhausting amount like by
the end of each series is run
I bet the producers were actually tired
of the rigmarole getting up walking on
stage lugging those heavy trophies
around after parties Breaking Bad has
won a hundred and fifty-one awards
including 16 Emmys even more important
was back in 2004 when The Sopranos
became the first cable program to win
the Emmy for most outstanding drama it
would go on to garner 21 Emmy wins and
113 overall victories
now it's commonplace for cable or
streaming shows to populate their
shelves with statues and they all owe a
debt of thanks to the Sopranos and you
better pay that debt back on time maybe
most iconic of all would be the way each
series said thank you
goodnight or in The Sopranos case thank
you good audiences and journey fans
around the globe were left with their
jaws on the floor when the Sopranos
finally stopped believing in the middle
of the scene so much tension so much
going on all over the tri-state area and
it was about to come to a head when the
lights simply went out and we faded to
black fans and critics had debated the
ending ever since and while its merits
may be in the eye of the beholder
nothing could spoil the season six party
that we had just experienced Breaking
Bad had a more definitive goodbye as
Walt he finally got his comeuppance and
Jesse
well he's skirting away in an El Camino
viewers likely appreciated this ending
more as many of those 10 million folks
were included in the Venn diagram of
Sopranos finale viewers who are left
with a little less closure both shows
are constantly referenced in all forms
of pop culture and each is revered as an
all-time iconic
television franchise so when it comes
down to it I am gonna give Breaking Bad
credit for sticking the landing a little
cleaner thank you for the inspiration
Sopranos but for me Breaking Bad wins
the round and we're tied at two two to
go
Gatorade me [ __ ] well if you're in
either one of these shows you definitely
don't want to hear the term sudden-death
but here we are it's up to me here's a
winner and to garner some insight to
help aid my decision
I went bravely to the Twitterverse in my
very official Twitter poll most fans
went with Breaking Bad however in my
replies things got heated and appeared
to end up with The Sopranos contingent
at least being more vocal here's some
soprano comments and Breaking Bad
certainly had its share of diehards too
and then we have like 40 likes on a
reply that was voting for Animaniacs
what's really great is we'll never stop
wanting to express our opinions about
which show is better because they're
both so good and endlessly rewatchable
The Sopranos started out as a small
series catering to fans of Goodfellas
and it became the Godfather against
which all other cable shows would be
judge Breaking Bad is just one of
countless shows inspired and it also
happens to be my pick for the winner of
this match
that's right Breaking Bad the genius
narrative events Gilligan's storytelling
a cinematic shooting style and inventive
techniques set a new standard still
unmatched since and to be honest its
closest competitor is probably better
call saw 3 watching The Sopranos has
been a delight and in my extended
research for this debate I found both
shows littered with great standalone
episodes and they also work in service
of the overall story well we can only
have one winner taking Breaking Bad
[Applause]
maybe it's just because I'd rather end
this show with a proper send-off and not
just fade to black hope they don't do
that to me so until next time I'm Mark
Ellis and I'm about to enter the witness
protection program
it's been fun but now I'm a tennis
instructor from Pasadena arrivederci
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]